tell me about Most Wanted and how is it
different than other shows Most Wanted
is very violent I mean it's in today's
age the criminals getting more violent
we are also taking the worst of the
worst off the streets we used to chase
bail jumpers and sometimes I put a guy
in for you know running on a fifty
thousand dollar bond and by the time
literally I got home to eat he was
calling me I'm out and it kind of made
me feel disappointed right so these guys
are not getting out most of them are got
a sentence to do they're on the run
these are wounded lions
these guys are wounded and would they
know that were the Predators predator so
these are really like what kind of
crimes when you talk about the most one
well something against people for
instance sexual assault on child sexual
assault of a young teenage child beating
his wife until you know she couldn't
even call 9-1-1 stabbing a guy in the
leg and trying to cut his artery in his
leg as he stabbed him it's guys like
that that really need to be put in a
cage is it scary when you're out there
sometimes I'll do anything to catch them
so if you're scared get out of it okay
are you cautious and worried always is
there some you worry about more than
others yes but scared maybe for a second
that might hit me but then I'm like I'm
going in what is the craziest situation
we'll see this season who well let's
just say it like this okay
our new vehicle on dogs Most Wanted is
an ambulance
you know people watch these shows under
many reality shows there's a script in
there you know they're it's it's reality
but not reality right but in this you're
out there with the real guys and
anything could happen yes well your
reality show - because I've this the
first show I've been on where the host
you didn't show me the questions you
forget ready to ask me so you shoot from
the hip just like we do and it I can't
stand it when the camera guy is a camera
guy you he's a fly on the wall fly get
on the wall you know cuz he's not me but
they'll try all my guys were like a
family as you know your family here and
they'll say why don't you say this cuz
I'm not that I'm not gonna do that so
they've learned now don't give us any
suggestions don't say anything what you
see is what you get you can't say listen
broad we can we reshoot that we missed
you we can we page you again you can't
do that so it's it's right raw its raw
when you talk about using tasers how
dangerous
does it get well your it's a kill or be
killed they're wanted dead or alive so
we were over 8,000 rest I've never
killed anyone
I am pure non-lethal weapons I you don't
need to kill a man
that's not your that's not how it should
be a guy's come with this at guns we do
have guns there are some firepower on
the team guys come we tase him or we use
a pepper ball gun which is a Mike Tyson
punch and then go down you cuff him
that's it I can't stand some of these
young kids that are getting shot because
they were running away from PD or he
came at me with a knife
well tase him you know wounding and
officers are not trained in to wound
they're trained to kill so we needed to
change some of that get none can you
guys 15 years on television so many went
down never have we had to kill one of
them and we've taken many out that we're
shooting as they're coming your team is
trained but it's a different team than
ever before
how is it different working on this show
well everybody has a job to do and they
all want to do their each other's job
and it's all mostly family and it's
grandkids now you know grandpa getting
better
cramp fighting I'm so proud to see that
stuff crazy to win your grandkids like
grandpa no crap all getting crap he's
mine yeah I mean I've had my son's doing
it right and my daughters and now the
grandkids are doing it
yes sir I showed you that in tonight
before Oh always ready I'll put it in
the camera once you see that the it's a
double-barrel taser it'll not only have
one so this will really take somebody
you hit somebody with a double-barreled
taser this will take them down oh yeah
35 feet away they're going to the ground
no matter what for 50 Marine Corps he's
going down when you pull this taser out
do they stop do they are they afraid of
this thing
no most are drugged out and so you go
what the drug tells them to do is charge
and then they get and they down all
right you got to catch them literally if
you don't think might hurt themselves
but it's not a gun you know they're not
gonna die you don't have to go to his
mother and say I'm sorry I killed your
baby and you don't have to dream about
his face coming at you at night right I
want to ask you this show is different
also because this is in a sense your
last ride with that well this I felt you
know I'm been around the country
advertising the show and of course we're
always talking about Beth right and I
told myself you know don't rub it in the
ground that's it you know quit doing
that that and then last night I thought
you know what this is her this is about
her struggle and her fight against
cancer so yeah she's in the whole thing
yeah she's there and now I felt better
about saying that all the time you know
so yes sir
what is it like watching her now it's uh
like she's there you know it's like
she's right there you also told me last
time we talked and I think that that is
something that so many people talked
about is that you go to bed and you put
pillows there to be like her still it my
dreams is when I see her and I'm with
third that helps and I still dreamed
about her yelling at me about something
crossing a lake or river we were
alligator huntin in South Carolina we
get away
are you stupid they bite that taser will
not go through that hide you chose to
show everything in this series as she
goes through that battle yes was there
anything that you thought that's a lot
Wow or were there any times that you
were like cameras just please go away
this is this woman is fighting for her
life
well every time DN Beth listen she goes
listen I'm showing it big Danny it
wasn't me that wanted to show some of
the stuff she is a very delicate woman
very look in the mirror the sideways
hotel room doesn't have a whole mirror
get one now bring it to the room oh my
god so some of the stuff she showed let
them in the room to see I was completely
flabbergasted how are you dealing with
this and how will you deal with it as it
plays out again well you'd be able to
watch oh the shows yeah oh yeah I like
that I'll be able to watch you know by
the cancer thing I see now why victims
of tragedies become how do you say it
when they have acute advocates for that
yeah I hope to god they don't have a
cure for cancer already and they're
sitting on it because if they do they
got a frickin problem with me I found
some things the CBD and the THC that was
mixed a doctor said if she wouldn't have
been on that she wouldn't die Dix months
ago I watched her get better taking that
and then I go the doctors oh we're not
trained in we're only trained in Western
medicine you know 150 grand per
treatment
hey get trained doc get off the old
horse and get on the new you know it's
it's terrible that it's a money-making
trillion dollar scam
we put felons in jail for the stuff they
do so how am i doing i I was embarrassed
last week to smile
why because I felt bad for smiling
because all he's supposed to be you know
morning and I'm still in mourning but
I'm smiling also so I don't know what
this is a thing I'm not used to
going through this so each step I take
I'll be able to help others and or get
over it myself what would you say to her
if you could give her one more message
if you could tell her you know how
thankful you are for this season and
what she did and how she sacrificed for
this season well I told the other day
let me off the map baby girl you got
more followers all the sub than I did
no I could never get the millions of hit
she got so I'm saying okay easy you win
I do that kind of all day because
everyone
sorry condolences and you know sorry
about bath dog even the guy in Starbucks
so you know it's it's a people been not
one well there's a couple but people
have been very very courteous and very
loving what's the moment that we're
gonna see that's gonna break our hearts
get a box of Kleenexes Brella the whole
show because you're like you do god oh
you miss the dog yeah oh that that it's
like in and out of Pow Wow
it's an emotional roller coaster right
oh my crying out dang it then throws a
kind of girl where she would come home
ago yeah if you see him and I watch a
show and the guy did something heroic if
I thought right which is really years
ago it's he's young I thought haha
Wendy get a load of me tonight baby so I
did all these heroic things for her and
because I got loving physical kissy
Kissy from her you know and piqué daddy
I'm so proud of you and that's why I
thought the other day that's why I was
such a nut because I had impress her
right so that's how she made me okay so
I'm still doing that it's really hard a
loan okay because soon he's getting
alone I am it hits you so I try not to
be alone
I mean I'm under supervision from my
whole group
my whole team you know the kids worse
dad don't leave him alone
my brother David he's not alone I'm
right here with you you know
but sometimes they know I got to be
alone but it hurts worse or you feel it
more when you're all alone and then now
the sudden I walk by all these girls and
dogs got a new girlfriend not yet I
don't dogs got a new girlfriend dogs got
a new girlfriend
I said hey mama I'll make you famous and
they're not really my girlfriend you
know so I'm not I'm saying I'm not gonna
have one cuz I will I'm not gonna get
married as I told you ever but so far
they struck out paparazzi's wrong stuff
my girlfriend I wanted to ask you about
that because you know everybody anytime
they see you with a woman they say oh
dogs already moved on he's moved on
right right
did you and better talk about that oh
yeah well yes because both of us did and
I said to her I know you're gonna date
look at you baby you know I ain't stupid
but please don't ever get married again
and she said you better not take the
name off my name off your chest I said
have two brass baths I'll put her name
on that say you better not add so don't
take that off and don't get married
because you can't say even biblical
characters when you know David one of
the greatest had a second wife so you
can't say that you it's it's unhuman but
you can say you won't get married I told
one the other day that I was kind of
looking at and I said listen to me it'll
never be another bise's dog so we're
gonna see you just keep giving them
google eyes you better know that right
now how long do you think before you
start dating yet I am so lonely
oh I'm not you know I'm gonna keep my
sexual preference but I'm so lonely
how's the rest of family doing
everybody's fine there were all the kids
that are in Hawaii are watching it all
together grandkids with the Cecily and
baby Lisa and then the ones that are
here flew in and they're Lila and I
think is gonna be the old one alone
these are mad anyway because y'all
bummed up but everyone's gonna watch it
you know it's just so freaking exciting
no it's like way better than Christmas
okay way better so I'm already 4000 all
right and then it's
he comes on the show and I'm like oh I
need water
will we see a second season I think so
but of course the network is like would
be thinking if I was in that working out
wait a minute the Beth will not be there
so it is the show going to be different
is this can he handle this is there he's
bragging about wait to you see dog
without Beth there ain't nobody it says
honey you make it kill stop right now I
don't hear that no more
so they don't know is it gonna be better
the same or as exciting so there's a lot
up in the air with that you still have
on your wedding oh yes sir I do you know
it's and it has a marker there yeah yeah
yeah yep we keep that this is stay right
there forever
I play with it and touch it all day
that's your way of thinking never did I
know what she put it on my finger what
it would mean to me mm-hmm - my favorite
thing I carried and proud of stuff was
my badge now it's my wedding ring I love
that talk about the store break-in what
happened
well someone hit our store our t-shirt
store we've kind of checked on it
through the internet or called made a
couple calls they haven't arrested the
guy yet but you know it's almost out of
sight out of mind you know what I mean
it's almost like yeah like you guys know
we tell me we don't think we figured it
out you're doing something special for
Vance today explain what you're gonna do
today well we have a big bus that has
been we WGN America has a big bus they
wrapped it and it's got you know dogs
most wanted and today brother we're
going dog walking do you think for this
because the reaction to you is pretty
amazing no one's ever seen nothing like
this because I start getting like
psychic with them right let's start like
hello you are you hitting her telling
John well only might get mad you hit her
again Joe give yourself on honey you hit
her again i'ma bust you up it is
incredible I mean it's just I've
love dog walking because you get to get
out there and talk to people and here's
the bus and you know very good idea WG
and hat they didn't have the dog walking
idea I did but all of a sudden today
when I found out what's going on I am oh
I get to show dog walking so it's gonna
be great by the way the house in Hawaii
you're gonna sell that house yes what's
gonna are you but will you stay in
Hawaii sometimes I have to stay in
Hawaii I have too many brothers sisters
are I have to sell that house yes know
that it's not morbid and she didn't pass
there but that's her house right my
house kind of was the Denver place her
house was Hawaii and you know everything
there I told you the toothbrush is still
my daughter's haven't touched the room I
thought you were packing dad we can't go
in there without you oh great
so everything like she had it so you
still have to go in there and clean all
that yes yes are you ready for that
no I went to the Denver house walked in
the closet and it smelled like her i sat
there and I wondered what is this you
know everybody was like okay put this
good will this and that not don't touch
it leave it when I walk in and you know
the pic all I do is straighten the
pictures out but I believe in it it's
not will it ever be ready to come down I
hope not you can see that's again with
someone else that I may like they got to
live with that you know you got it you
got a yeah I may have to go farmers calm
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]